christian d'abord un message d'espoir du
gouvernent du président barack obama
écoutez on a senti ce soir un président
qui n'a pas besoin d'être réélu qui ne
s'en va pas en ré élection un discours
très progressiste très libérale très à
gauche qui doit actuellement indisposé
plusieurs républicains qui écoutent le
discours en direct du congrès le
président qui bien sûr a mentionné aux
américains que ces politiques et ces
décisions avaient permis aux états unis
de sortir de cette très très difficile
crise économique qui a frappé le pays en
2008 et 11 millions d'emplois qui ont
été créés depuis cinq ans aux états unis
obamacare son assurance maladie a permis
à 10 millions d'américains d'obtenir une
couverture et qu'il allait imposer son
veto
toute loi qui allait freiner les progrès
des états unis en ce moment alors je
vous laisse entendre le président obama
qui a dit que maintenant la page était
tournée
rsb christian un discours usé très
progressiste très à gauche on sent aussi
qu'il met le congrès au défi il a parlé
de son veto en fait ils allaient
l'utiliser si on essayait de le freiner
dans ces réformes la wii et sa ses
larmes ultime de tout président
d'utiliser un veto il a mentionné qu'il
allait ne pas hésiter à le faire si
jamais les républicains 30 ans tu es
dans trop de de démanteler sa réforme de
la santé de démanteler sa réforme de
l'immigration
on l'a proposé toute une série de
mesures c'est plutôt rare qu'on entend
parler de garderie lors d'un discours de
l'état de l'union en congé maladie
de congés de maladie le salaire minimum
effectivement il a mentionné qu'il
allait octroyer des déductions d'impôt
de 3000 $ par enfant pour permettre
justement aux américains moyens
d'envoyer leurs enfants à la garderie
il a mentionné qu'avec 43 millions
d'américains en ce moment qu'il n'avait
pas de congés de maladie garantie par
leur entreprise il entend remédier à ça
il a parlé d' égalité de salaire entre
hommes et femmes est là aussi parler du
salaire minimum on sait que c'est un
combat que mène barack obama depuis
maintenant quelques mois il veut
augmenter le salaire minimum à 10
dollars 10 pour l'ensemble des
américains et il a mis le défi il a mis
le congrès au défi les républicains
particulièrement de tenter de faire
vivre une famille avec 15000 dollars par
année
je vous laisse entendre écouter le
président des états unis
et venant bon chez gainward bras le bébé
m'intéresse
oui le président qui a été applaudi à de
nombreuses reprises par les démocrates
bien sûr et évidemment il n'a pas pu
éviter tout le projet de kystes on
excelle tout ce débat qu'il ya aux états
unis sur ce pipeline
ils forcent beaucoup en ce moment ils
poussent énormément si line pour que les
infrastructures à travers les états-unis
soient rénovés et effectivement la
lancer une flèche bien senti au projet
qu'ils tombent
barack obama qui est contre ce projet de
pipeline qui traverserait les états unis
et qui permettrait au pétrole de
l'alberta de se rendre aux raffineries
du texas
il a toujours mentionné que ça créerait
que des emplois temporaires alors il a
dit au lieu d'adopter un projet de loi
pour permettre la construction de ce
pipeline
pourquoi pas adopté un projet de loi qui
remettraient les infrastructures
américaines à niveau alors je vous
laisse entendre encore
il a été bien sûr un terminant céline de
lutte contre le terrorisme les états
unis qui ont l'intention de poursuivre
leur lutte contre le groupe etat
islamique le groupe arbel état islamique
et légalement été question de libre
échange avec l'europe et l'asie et de
diplomatie
oui mais de force militaire si
nécessaire